[موسيقى]
توافد كبير وطاقه قصوى للمسجد الحرام في
استقبال مئات الالاف من المعتمرين والزوار
يوميا خلال شهر رمضان هذه الاعداد الكبيره
تتطلب تطويرا مستمرا للخدمات عبر قياسي
رضاهم عن الخدمات المقدمه تعمل اداره
تجربه ضيف الرحمن وفق معايير متبعه من
مركز اداء الوطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه
كذلك تعمل الاداره على اربع ورديات مختلفه
تقوم بقياس نسبه الرضا وفق معايير معتمده
من مركز اداء الوطني لقياس الجهات
الحكوميه ايقوم يقوم الفريق الميداني في
النزول على ارض الواقع واخذ الانطباعات
مباشره ورفع تقارير لحظيه مسوحه احصائيه
ميدانيه تجريها وكاله قياس الاداء والجوده
بالرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام بشكل
يومي حيث تستهدف
خمسه الاف معتمر ومصلل يقوم المختصين لدى
المركز بعمليه المقابله الشخصيه مع
المعتمرين
وسؤالهم عن المده المستغرقه في كل قسم من
هذه الاقسام الخاصه بالعمره سواء في
الطواف او في السعي او المده الانتقال بين
الطواف والسعيد وبعد ذلك يقوم مركز
الاحصاء والمعلومات باخذ متوسط مده
المتوسط مده العمره جاهزيته المصليات
واعمال النظافه واداره الحشود ابرز
الخدمات التي يجري بحط رضا المعتمرين عنها
لتفادي اي اخطاء فيما تبقى من شهر رمضان
واستعدادا للموسم الاكبر موسم حج هذا
العام
من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه